pour vous justement cette france
est-elle de droite écoutez facialement
si on regarde les chiffres effectivement
je dirais comme mes collègues autour du
plateau si on regarde les chiffres on
al'impression effectivement qu'il ya une
tendance plutôt à droite mais quelle
droite c'est bien le sujet du débat si
on considère que les populistes les
démagos sont de droite si on regarde
emmanuel macron il est quoi est-il
réellement de gauche ou de droite ou de
gauche droite et de gauche moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup plus à la majorité
silencieuse à tous ces électeurs qui
vont pas forcément voté ou ceux qui se
trouvaient sur les ronds points lors de
la crise des gelées jaune et qui ont des
messages justement sociétale économique
sur l'emploi et ces gens là ils
demandent pas forcément un programme de
droite donc je pense pas forcément que
la france est à droite et qu'aujourd'hui
on puisse réellement avoir ce constat là
c'est un constat facile qui est souvent
servi par les populistes
[Musique]